i mean the suit i can't let's talk about
it let's talk about it who are you
wearing
this is um dolce gabbana it's a good
sentence to say right
um we're here vanity fair oscar's party
this is a big moment does it feel like
an i made it moment yes this definitely
feels like one of them for sure i've had
a couple of them throughout my uh past
seven months here but yeah this is
definitely a big one and we got the
crown yeah right you know your crown is
always ready as soon as you find the
courage to wear it yeah okay yes yes
um so big nights did you watch the show
i watched the show yeah you know i got
to ask you what'd you think of the will
moment oh that was incredible that's
incredible you know i just feel like
it's what he said you know you have to
protect your family and uh you know i
believe in him and what he stands for
and so you know he's a stand-up guy and
i'll stick by him have you texted with
him spoken to him at all uh not yet not
tonight
i don't even look i don't expect a text
back but is it one of those things where
you text him and say hey man i'm
thinking of you or anything oh yeah yeah
you know we've been in contact yeah yeah
what was your reaction when you watched
it knowing him because we were all i
mean dude when he won it i was like i
mean it was just such an emotional
moment in general it was like
i you know i knew it was him i know it's
him i already said it's already written
you know what i mean i believed it and
he manifested it and his work has proved
it throughout the years you know he
definitely deserved it and then that
speech with the the tears
incredible incredible i was like the
fact that i am an extension of this
legacy
is such an amazing opportunity and such
an amazing honor and so the fact that i
could see him you know express those
emotions in front of the whole world was
so was so endearing i have to ask you
look people on online of course are
they're talking about
the moment where he hit chris rock and
there's some criticism of that what do
you say to those people what's your take
on it knowing will oh man no answer for
that yeah
uh so tonight uh you're getting in there
who's your date tonight
oh you know i just with a friend right
now okay well uh what is it gonna look
like for you hitting the dance floor how
do you have fun i'm about to rip it up
i'm about to rip it up i hope i see you
in there yeah you're gonna see me i'm
gonna be out here working okay
got you um the williams sisters are in
there
have you ever met them at all yes i've
met them and they're wonderful they're
wonderful um met the family and uh it's
amazing amazing yeah the show has been
so well received what's it all been like
for you i mean it's an incredible honor
you know it's like
there was definitely skepticism
someone's walking in there's definitely
skepticism around the show before it
came out but you know but the fact that
it was received was so much love from
our community and from the world it emit
the world to me any message to the fans
who are watching tonight uh thank you
all for sticking by us thank you for
watching belair and showing your support
and your love and we appreciate it in
season two we're going to elevate the
whole situation i hope you're ready you
know because you were just talking about
will and being an extension of him
you've worked so closely with him what
have you learned from him what have been
the takeaways from your time with him i
mean every conversation with that man is
something where i walk away like what
did i just just do you know what i mean
and like you know i think my biggest one
was definitely
he said something that really stuck with
me he said don't let the failures
you know don't let the successes get to
your head don't let the failures get to
your heart
and that's a word right there